nick's here with his dog chewie from
maine obviously
mexico actually oh really mexico yeah
he's born in mexico
and he has autism yeah he's got
something
he's getting cuter though i'll give you
that heads up though he did drink half
this espresso
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
that top layer reminds me of like a
queen mattress with that fluffer on the
top
biceps bigger than your mom's tits
that's true
my mom has a cups your mom had your mom
flat chested
i mean bro i wouldn't describe her like
that but
you know she's a male she's a female
yeah
but she had those small [ __ ] milk
rattlers on her boy
it was hard to get a drop out of them my
mom wasn't giving up anything man
you got to work though ah you got to
work
dude i would do i would do side control
on the tit
trying to get it down you know trying to
get a half ounce out of one of them put
that 10 in the ankle like that
i remember breastfeeding off my brother
for a little while oh yeah
just because he was always better than
that's it i had a better chance of
getting something out of him yeah or
trying to i remember those videos
there's not videos of it but there's
drawings of it
that's probably got those haunches man
getting that thick
[ __ ] brother sweat out you think
now were you sucking on his tits before
after he had those tattoos
because that that messed you up
well he uh
oh they got that dog huh wasn't that dog
in uh
i know what you did last summer i know
this dog was in uh as good as it gets
that's jack nicholson's dog you steal
that dog damn nick i know you had pink
undies on
and you can see that dog sweat a little
when he goes over there by chin man
no homo bro do you know what i'm saying
that dog has anxiety when he goes
overboard
definitely he hears that griddle warm up
in the back of his head yeah boy
oh yeah it's tasting me
it's getting cuter though dude the
tables have turned
i'm just saying dude bark lives matter
bro that's it
it's tired it knows what you did to its
people dude yeah paul's matter chin not
me
yeah not you but somebody somewhere
somewhere somewhere down the line maybe
yeah someone look man we've all there's
all of us are carrying around all kind
of
monsters in the closet monsters in our
freaking marrow
in our in our in our dna the bone marrow
you're about to go bone marrow
oh you put on that chain doggy that jc
penny chain this is a 100 tungsten
oh damn dog you get that where'd you
where'd you you
sponsored by express today where'd you
get that shirt i won this actually two
years ago to fair down in uh
naples see that that's kind of like your
dog right nick
you look like you sell timeshares and
van eyes really yeah this shirt is sick
i'll give you that dude dude you look
like you sell
toothpaste by the mouthful of gay dudes
okay
that's it you look like bro crest just
to the game
like a third baseman for [ __ ] colgate
all men's butt first team
you guys are the only guys who play
backwards so
the guy hits it yeah you have to catch
it with your butt
and you have to run with your butt and
then slide in butt first
it's all safe
but there's nothing safe going on out
there there's nothing safe about it
no condoms in that league no sir there
are no
dhs not a chance who's this gentleman so
we have a guy oh this is our boy last
week who uh
first of all i want to say last week man
great episode oh thanks brother dude i
tuned in just to make sure you guys got
the episode up dude because
obviously i don't trust a lot of people
that work here yeah and um
yeah and it is fair yeah and um and
it was awesome i watched the whole
episode i watched the whole episode man
you enjoyed it yeah it was good did you
like subscribe hambile didn't say
anything or whatever that guy's name is
i'm glad he didn't pork chop out the
back
whatever
yeah no this guy was uh he this is the
guy who didn't win the date
i know and we were rooting for him do we
hear about the from the firefighter
uh we we haven't yet uh spoke with him i
wanted to wait till
he's too cool he don't give a [ __ ]
hurricane he's so cool he's fighting
fires man
uh oh the firefighter he was he was sad
he missed it he was like really he was
like i wanted to try to face it
because he was actually fighting fires
in utah and he's like i wanted to try to
facetime in but no service
um that guy's a legend there's no
service in a fire
no you have to do that fires the
original electricity dude i doubt
there's no service in there
he was such a badass but uh this guy
uh he was a little sad about losing last
week but uh he's got a debate club that
i think will help lead us into uh
our guest actually oh hey what's up
cat's crew it's gavin
uh the guy you may know me the guy who
got his heart ripped out and broken last
week
um still single still hurt
but i got a quick debate club for you
guys
who do you got in the upcoming fight
connor the legend
or dustin the dog um
i mean personally i know you guys could
probably deep dive into this so
i'd love to hear your opinion i also
need to know i need a bet to make to uh
make me a little money to uh
you know take over for this heartbreak
this void that's in my soul right now
oh you would never give up but besides
that love the show keep doing what
you're doing
gang gang buzz buzz he's married anyway
and we're straight
i mean you're nuts well this of all
first of all gavin thank you very much
for chiming in brother we appreciate it
and i'm sorry that uh
we're gonna find him a lady i'm sorry
that that's
that's that salt flat thought let you
down
last week man a little i don't know
she don't she don't like that pepper in
her salt do you feel me i don't think
man
nope and look if you're lonely and still
single and broken-hearted dude
then this past weekend is the podcast
for you brother
it's up it's out every week and you will
thrive over there
you cry together we welcome you too
also stop chasing a girl who orders only
white meat at kfc you feel me
yeah yeah dude that girl likes it
white dude you could smell that from a
mile away
yeah your boy's fighting this weekend
you're going to the fight yeah dude i'm
going to
fall dressed like that who's there
me dude if you dress like that i feel
like you can get beat
up dude i'll freaking dress dude i'll
fight anybody in the stands dude we'll
do it
who's going to be there i know chandler
will be there off if i have to fight him
i'll fight him
that's your buddy who else bros would be
there i would love to see them just slap
you around a little bit
yeah say something to them let me know
how it goes for you nah nah nah
do that i might leave a note for him but
i'm not saying leave a note and run off
uh it's a good question man what do i
have i'm excited for your boy poirier
i'm either way it's a payday for the man
either way it's a payday people are
excited the whole car is great you got
wonderboy thompson out there with
who's he fighting dorino gilbert gilbert
burns
that's gonna be wild um
great fight i think warner boy knocked
him out you do yep i'd love to see one
boy get a shot at usman he will if you
knocked him out and i'm not talking
about kamara i'm talking about the guy
from 90 day fiance
yeah [ __ ] that dude
yeah that's a great [ __ ] call that
guy needs his [ __ ] ass
the other way son come out here what's
up
yeah that's it right there trick that
poor young lady
dude this whole their whole story was
way better than coming to america too
what's the synopsis huh what'd you do to
him
uh he so he basically tricked her con
turned
uh her marrying him so he'd get into the
states
yeah i feel like she'd be stoked on it i
don't know oh she was over there bro
they were raising goats they were doing
it all she painted her face
yeah they definitely got uh she was
down and he was having to hammer that
figlet every night
wake up two dried out bro he was paying
for that green card
that dude yeah yeah even it was uh
the piper yeah he paid the piper with
some [ __ ]
penis brother that's what he did he paid
penis and look at freaking your boy back
there dude porky chop
yeah whatever that guy's name is bro
seaman giblet
he [ __ ] looks like he's been eating
boo radley biscuits back there dude
are you okay give a look in your eyes
like you want to be a serial killer but
you don't want to put in the work
uh should we bring in an expert to help
us
yeah yeah yeah i'll kill them tomorrow
i would do it but they seem nice
mcgregor poor a3 is all set
no you can be there in person and i want
you to hold up my [ __ ] cash
when i win but listen if you're not
betting theo vaughn i'm probably going
to lose your money you can bet
with draftkings this weekend's big ufc
264
is this weekend and they're offering you
guys 264
to one odds on a knockout in the first
round during saturday's main event
if the rubber match ends on a first
round knockout you walk away with cash
wow just pick the main event fighter you
think will win by first round
poor a or conor probably mean conor's
first round knockout
and with draftkings they will give you
264 to one odds on that fighter that's
right
bet one dollar on mcgregor poirier to
win by first round knockout and you win
264. i
don't know that that's right download
the top rated draftkings
sportsbook app and now and use promo
code kats when you sign up to turn
one dollar into 264 dollars
when you bet on a main event fighter to
win by first round ko place your bet
watch the fists fly that's right that's
code kats to turn
one dollar into 264 dollars i can't
believe that it's a lot of money
only at draftkings sportsbook must be 21
or older njin or pa
only those are states new customers only
restricted supply i see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 1800 gambler
or in indiana 1-800
i had something the other day that
wasn't very fresh
actually oh man well you need to get
america's number one meal kit with hello
fresh
hello fresh hello fresh cuts out
stressful meal planning
and grocery store trips so you can enjoy
cooking and get dinner on the table and
ready
30 minutes or less theo vaughn try hello
fresh quick and easy meals
15 to 20 minute dinners practice on the
go we got you covered
and more easy options to fit your busy
lifestyle
all right we love it here hello fresh
28 cheaper than shopping at your local
grocery store and 72 percent cheaper
than restaurants go to hellofresh.com
slash
14 king use the code 14 king for up to
14 free meals
plus free shipping again that's
hellofresh.com
14k 14 king for up to 14
free meals plus free shipping yeah we
got an expert
yeah let's bring an expert to help us
discuss connor dustin
that handsome bastard oh is it great to
be with you man is that a blue jay's hat
you're wearing yes sir
that's sharp right there thanks man i'm
not even a blue jays fan i just like the
hat and the color
oh i j you just appreciate good gear and
good logos god you look good man what
have you been doing
moisturizing what's going on here no i
mean i was outside it is so goddamn hot
here i was outside a little bit today
trying to get some sun because i'm
wearing a [ __ ] pink suit on
television saturday night and it doesn't
look good unless i'm like
really dark so that's where we're at
john annick baby the tame
panic right there himself dude thanks
for joining us bro
what an absolute pleasure to be with you
guys especially to talk to theo during a
dustin poirier fight week and and my man
chaba and i have been trying to get
together and chop it up for like years
so uh this is true
i've been doing it with him for years
you ain't missing nothing
[Laughter]
i'll tell you that dude i'm so excited
for this week uh
how are you feeling what are you feeling
going into this it's a connor fight week
for you
yeah man i'm anxious you know and
anxious in the best of ways obviously i
don't have to tell you guys this will be
the first time that we have a full crowd
in vegas since march of 2020.
i feel like this is as sought after a
ticket
in ufc history like i'm getting text
messages from people in my life that i
haven't heard from in five to ten years
so
if that's an indicator i think we're
gonna do a good number on pay-per-view
and
i just think the most interesting part
of this for me is that these dudes went
like six or seven years from fight one
to fight two and now this
third fight is happening only six months
after that second meetings
so uh a lot obviously on the line in
terms of the mixed martial arts legacy
for both guys but um
i don't know man i think from a vetting
perspective i think if you like
conor the price is a whole lot better
than it was at ufc 257 earlier this year
agree it's a tough fight to call though
right annik like you look at the fight
you can't go based off six years ago
when they first fought two completely
different fighters
you can't really go based off that fight
in january because you know connor's
been focused on boxing obviously poor
a's been active so it's not like
i don't put too much into that fight
either so this one is like to me is
whoever wins this one's like
literally going to be the winner of this
trilogy because now no i think congress
will focus
you know yeah i think whoever wins this
fight can lay claim to be in the better
fighter in this series
and for dustin poirier i think his
biggest advantage and again i could go
so deep on the numbers right this dude
has 11 ufc lightweight wins conor
mcgregor has
one ufc lightweight win it's absolutely
crazy that we don't talk about poirier
as one of the all-time greats in this
sport because he's never been an
undisputed ufc champion but
he has had all of this mma developmental
time during
his prime he hasn't taken more than six
or eight weeks off throughout his entire
career
juxtaposed against conor mcgregor who
has had major pockets of inactivity not
just in competition
but in training as well so i just think
my biggest takeaway
is pourier's confidence right the reason
he's not keeping things close to the
best the reason why he's talking a whole
lot
is because he doesn't care like
confidence is overflowing that he
doesn't care what he says
he thinks nine times out of ten he beats
this next do you guys and you guys i
know you
you talked about the fights of dustin
head you got you didn't even mention the
ones dustin used to fight dudes
in lafayette in front of the police
station bro because he knew they were
both getting arrested
so he would meet him at the police
station to fight right there because
he's such a nice guy he didn't want the
cops to have to travel
here's here's the thing to me on that
that's a true story yeah i believe it
great
here's the thing to me on this fight
this fight to me is dictate on how much
does conor want it
you know because connor you know he has
more money than god you know the the
proper whiskey sold
they reported 100 million my sources say
he's
he's got way more money than that and he
has all the money from the floyd fight
and obviously
the the he's making money from the ufc
so we know he has more money than god to
me with connor it's like
are you willing to die in there because
we know dustin is dustin is a
dog man and he doesn't get the respect
he wants so if connor
if he can take it or leave it he's gonna
get beat up but if if he's doing it for
a legacy i think we got a real fight on
our hands dustin told me he would fight
the devil one time if he knew where he
lived at
isn't that crazy he told me that it
makes sense and he told me not to tell
anybody and i shouldn't have said
anything
but he said it but he missed out i gotta
ask you this outside of that fight
that dustin will win in the third round
outside of that fight
give me a little insight on my boy no
nonsense keith peterson you gave him the
name
yeah i love the guy like every time i
see him do it i want to go to the
7-eleven and [ __ ] buy a pack of new
ports you know what i'm saying like
yeah i want to get a neck tattoo when i
say it yeah dude i love him man and i'm
going to beat his funeral if he ever
dies i'll be right there in the
front row there but yeah i'll send a
note tell me about him a little bit
i will go with you and uh we'll rip some
dirt sticks together you're right like
i'm around that dude
and he makes me want to smoke a
cigarette like
you know he makes me want to drink a
beer and smoke a cigarette and i will
tell you too
like for that whole thing with dominic
cruz i was a little bit in between
because dominic cruz is one of my best
friends i came to keith peterson's
defense publicly
keith will be the first to tell you they
told him he had five minutes to go
[ __ ] rip a lung dart before the
fighter meeting he went and did it so
right before he's talking to these guys
but he definitely was sober but i love
the guy and
you know i think the reason why i came
to his defense because
he only recently got approved by the
nevada state athletic commission to
actually referee fights here and it took
him forever
and so i kind of felt like that public
criticism from dom might hurt his cause
in other jurisdictions so i think he's
one of the best refs i mean obviously
these guys
make mistakes every now and again but
yeah i am a huge fan of the
no-nonsense keith peterson where's the
mustache man how you gonna shave the
mustache for the
connor fight i mean it's kind of there
what what's crazy is that like i could
literally grow a mustache in 48 hours
you know
if i would make that you should do a
time lapse video put it on youtube
so yeah the mustache will be back by uh
by saturday night
now what about this man you guys sitting
there whenever you guys the shock thing
has started to become like a thing it's
almost like watching like
three stone dudes watching shark week or
something when when there's a big
knockout and you and daniel and joe all
kind of like
has it started to become a thing it
almost seems like you guys are on like a
roller coaster like you guys
know now everyone's like i'm like it was
all right
yeah yeah i mean i can i can assure you
at least for me
it's like that camera is in front of joe
so i'm not even paying attention to it
by the way i think we're all probably
residually stoned by the time we show up
uh on fight night but
yeah i mean fans love this [ __ ] right
like for a play-by-play guy as soon as
like
jorge mosquito knocks out ben askren and
i cap that fight
they're giving me traffic immediately
like all right do this [ __ ] do that
you know so for me
the last thing i'm thinking about is
that camera and ultimately as the
play-by-play guy i kind of have to make
sure i provide the historical context
for the moment
before i think about anything else but
it's been fun i mean
rogan's reactions are just unbelievable
it looks like his eyes like
are trying to protrude and leave his
head you know
but it's been fun man i mean i don't
have to tell you guys like it's just
different when joe's there man it's just
more special yeah you guys coming
theo's going i i don't like going to
live events especially ufc i
have anxiety these days from it well and
i'm sure for both of you guys
uh there'd be a little crowd navigation
this weekend but uh
theo's gonna be there though i'll be
there baby i'll see i'm sitting right
behind you guys
theo's gonna be there in a thong i'll be
in a thong rooting for dustin poirier
now if dustin loses i need you to find
him and console him cause he'll be
crying yeah yeah yeah
fight he's yelling out instructions
that's true actually they're like dude
they're
they're not even on the ground theo
guillotine
oh yeah i told joe i would be on my best
behavior this time so he's letting me go
back but uh
i'm fired up dude i'll be right behind
you guys if dustin wins one of y'all's
getting molested bro i promise you that
[ __ ] jump me man i can't wait for it
but yeah no that'll be good to meet you
in person and have you right behind us
and uh it's just so good having fans
back in the building like i'm going back
and watching film of ufc 258 for gilbert
burns and kamara usman and i was like
i'm doing this whole pay-per-view open
in an empty ufc apex with
25-foot octagon i know hey how awkward
was it when uh
i got to ask you about this how awkward
was it when diego sanchez and joshua
fabia
was in was in that room and just started
spouting all that [ __ ] towards you
and me and
megan o'leavy and freaking paul felder
and
well you know joshua fabia right and
i've said this publicly
that dude is like the least self-aware
individual that i've ever met and yet he
runs a school of self-awareness
which is just crazy you know but i have
to say like
i respect these athletes to such an
extent and i have diego sanchez in front
of me
literally welling up with [ __ ] tears
because he feels like venom coming back
from the broadcast team
so i kind of went into damage control
mode and laid back and i knew i was
going to just bring diego into the
hallway and kind of talk him off the
ledge
but here he is however mentally
compromised
trying to sort of explain his piece to
this room and he's literally filling up
with tears so my focus very quickly
shifted
to trying to make diego feel better it's
a sad situation all around the worst
phabia is pretty blown he's he's out
there man you know not that he is
not i mean he has merit like i do think
he has some value
but uh he's just not aware enough of
self to really uh
make a a positive difference for diego i
was hoping paul felder just stood up and
beat the [ __ ] out of him
yeah i mean i think paul was uh was
inclined to do so the assault charge i
looked it up recently
it's not like a terrible thing
no it's not awful you know like you know
europe be all right paul
we'll get a gofundme yeah we'll get yeah
we'll bail him out
i don't know why i looked that up
recently i was thinking about assaulting
somebody
and i looked it up just to see what the
penalty would be it's not too bad
it's worth the risk is there a favorite
cornerman or trainer or something that
you like that's fun to just have there
on the apron when you guys are uh
calling it when you're out there at the
fights is there like one or two that
really kind of stand out to you that are
just
like oh this is almost like just another
thing that that you get to see that
you don't really get to see it from the
television broadcast is there anybody
that stands out
definitely the general safe saud from
fortis mma i just
love watching him light up his guys and
not mince words and i think he has a lot
of young athletes that sort of blindly
swear by his every word so he's not
afraid to light them up but
yeah i'm always trying to get them to go
to that safe saud i thought you were
going to say ray longo
i know you'd think right a guy who's
been on my podcast for 305 episodes that
i would shout out ray no rey's
outstanding and i think ray's a little
bit underrated in terms of
his ability to teach cardio and to uh
to really resonate with his athletes in
the corner so yeah
honorable mention to my guy long ago but
mark mark henry is pretty special if you
listen to mark henry with frankie edgar
and some of the other guys
it's like he's playing a favorite game
yeah he's playing video game he tells
them what to do and they have they talk
in code
and every fight the language is
different oh wow they have
they download a whole database and he
gives out these code words and they
literally like he has a control and they
do what he says it's pretty nuts
yeah like mike brown i like mike brown
too oh mike brown's the [ __ ] best man
he's going skins a lot this week he must
be in pretty good shape i noticed
really yeah he's going to pick a bad
joke he should do a calendar
they should do a mma coach they should
do it everybody long ago it's december
with his shirt
get them tits out long ago yeah i like
them long island tits out bro
oh that'd be so great uh john we don't
want to take up all your time man this
is so
awesome dude john anak is here i'm
learning i feel like i'm almost
somebody should fight in here today dude
i will say and i hope to be in studio
with you guys at some point right like
despite some of the erroneous headlines
out there i'm not training for like an
amateur mma fight right now but i will
say
when you spend enough time around this
sport and these athletes
it's hard not to want to develop some
skills
like i [ __ ] hate jiu jitsu but it's
hard not to want to develop some
striking skills and like
do an amateur boxing match against my
twin brother right because i'm around
this so much
that it gives you the urge to to punch
somebody in the face
well we have we'll do king of the sting
promotions we'll put that [ __ ] on if
you want to fight your brother
let's do it it's uh in the bantamweight
division he has a ponytail hair down to
his shoulders but i think we could build
it oh he didn't tell me as a ponytail is
his cornerman
joshua fabia or what i'm sure fabia
would take his call but i don't know
[Laughter]
well we love you man you're all my
favorite people on this planet dude we
yeah we got to get together man in
person we got to figure it out
the love is mutual thank you guys for
having me on and uh don't be strangers
theo i'll give you a big hug in uh
about 72 hours my man that sounds great
man and which what is the podcast where
people can check out your pod
well thanks man the anakin flooring
podcast with brandon shobs guy ken flo
former three-time ufc title challenger
we go live pretty much every monday and
have been doing it for about six years
it's one of my favorite shows
cool two of my favorite guys my man cool
man
yeah john thank you so much dude see you
this weekend thank you boys enjoy the
show i'll see you guys soon
get that mustache popping daddy let's do
it all right brother
love you man boys love you too brother
this is all you daddy
all right if you need help
then you're talking to the right guy
i've needed help most of my life
so i'll need a little help yeah you need
help from a professional
you got to quit listening to me on
happiness dude i don't know
i just go talk to a real licensed
professional that better help dude that
is true actually brendan doesn't know he
just goes though and there's some value
in that
uh i kind of stutter step a lot so i
need some help
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches
that make it easy and free to change
counselors if you don't want to go
see a therapist in your town or in your
domicile or prison if you're in prison
right a pizza hut yeah or if you're
trapped in a pizza hut then you can get
help still at least on your phone you
can do it on facetime you can do it over
the phone
um or you can even do it through text
message that's right
you can get help visit betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s that's b-e-t-t-e-r help
get ten percent off man this podcast
sponsored by better help and king of the
sting
listeners and viewers get temps off
their first month at betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s i want diamonds
and i want pearl diamonds all forever
i want a blue now diamond dog i want
oh what you looking for a wedding ring
for your girl find jewelry for your man
i want the wristlet
oh whatever it is dog i got you covered
with a [ __ ] wristlet boy
blue nile man with that [ __ ] pierce
thing
oh we can't do that build the engagement
ring of her or his
dreams with bluenow.com whether you're
customizing an engagement ring
for that special someone or designing
diamond stud earrings at bluenile.com
you're in control
it's cheaper there than going to a brook
and mortar store because they don't have
no brook and mortar it's online
what cut out the middle man man pick
from a vast selection of preset diamond
gemstone jewelry blue now offers endless
options
ready to ship the same day we also got
you covered man blue now has jewelry
experts on hand
twenty four seven yep each diamond is a
gia graded which allows you to view the
unique qualities
carrot weight color cut be confident
it's different from other competitors
they don't mark up that's right
blue nile has a diamond price guarantee
contact blue nile
to compare a competitor's diamond
against one of ours in most cases
they'll meet or beat their price 100
satisfaction
guarantee make the moment sparkle with
jewelry from bluenile.com
and king and the sting listeners get 50
off 500
this podcast exclusive offer includes
engagements wow
use code kats that's code cats plus
every order is insured
ships free arrives the street little
package so it doesn't give it away man
your lady will have no idea
shop stress free and find your forever
piece go to bluenile.com today
dude that's cool i feel like we're at
the fight he's one of my favorite people
man i love john
it's so concise how he says everything
it's almost like he's like a chef
about fighting mm-hmm there's nobody
when it's him dc and rogan there's not a
better
commentating team in sports than those
three not even close
it's funny i hadn't thought about it to
that extent that like yeah it's like one
i realized the other day ufc is my
favorite sport somebody asked what your
favorite sport is not watch anything
else though right
well i always usually would say football
but then i thought about it for a second
like college football right like lsu
yeah you'll get one big college football
games we'll talk about that but
yeah you got really into fighting it's
just interesting dude
but i think even what he said at the end
by the end it's like you want to learn
some of it you want to just be
involved in it somehow you know even if
you're getting
beat up by [ __ ] 60 chicks dude
there's some kid with a bad eye they
made me fight like about six weeks ago
yeah an eye patch
a little woman and uh and i don't i mean
it was a woman then
she probably had some fire though by
scrappy
oh definitely definitely man uh but it's
also the only sport where like if you're
into it there's a way to do it right
like you can play basketball i guess
with your friends or whatever but
if you're into mixed martial arts you
could do boxing to get in shape you'd do
something you know like
jiu jitsu kickboxing like him be part of
it that's
dope about it yeah and there's all kind
of small tournaments everything
you're going to conor mcgregor fight i
know so like there's
the super ball and then there's a conor
mcgregor fight and i know you're boys
with poirier and
he's a he's probably like good chance
he's gonna win the fight but it's just
you're going to literally the fight i
know
i know dude i was so excited the other
day i couldn't even think bring a stay
at circus circus
i don't know i'm i asked my agent to try
to give me a hotel room
agent won't you put on your big boy
pants and [ __ ] buddy yourself
you're just like i don't know dude look
up [ __ ] expedia what look like
[ __ ]
do whatever bro put those bastards to
work dude yeah you can pay them 10
percent you [ __ ] look expedia dog
i'll let them pay for 90 of that room
and i'll pay for 10
of that [ __ ] dude oh there you go right
there there's nick right there
2015 i was a hipster conor mcgregor fan
before love it
wow but now i'm now i'm rooting for
dustin it's crazy hell
no thanks james i love dustin one of my
favorite people
he just i mean look the guy said he's
it's only been he has only had six weeks
off in
70 years or whatever the guy he's a hall
of famer
he's a hands down bar none hall of famer
dude thanks for letting me even just be
on fire on the wall with you guys
talking it's interesting bro
yeah sorry i you know you know we're
caught up so i didn't want to
make it so heavy i got to answer the
things i want to keep peterson
and if they start to think it becomes
like a bit when they do that thing dude
that's the best picture ever
yeah but now like a guy like it'd be
like a decision when they're old
hey man i feel like you guys doing this
for the gram yeah brogan's all
mind-blowing they're like those
youtubers like
oh yeah that's the freaking worst bro
who's this freaking
thirst trap with his shirt off this is
your brother yeah it was where
fourth of july was popping in florida
and we got some people sending in from a
party
field brennan's shop we're coming in
from fort lauderdale
theo shop brandon bond we're coming to
you from sunny fort liquor elf florida
we got a debate club for you
[Music]
oh damn winds over here baby king you're
the sing baby
let us know dang that lady looks like
she's gonna complain
he did not look pleased with that yeah
he can't go his nose deep in somebody's
[ __ ]
with this bloodline in there not my man
it's 20 21 dog yeah i will say [ __ ]
matter
go back both women look violated
she's picking her wedgie out oh i'm sure
what's her name uh
chelsea piretti will tweet about this
i'm sure we ruined these women's lives
somehow that [ __ ] target
as long as she can sell some tickets on
i know
marry your way into it um did that look
like your weekend
we can't all be funny no my weekend was
a little bit different man yeah my
weekend was not like that this is theos
this is my weekend right here
are you at a ymca
is this a trump rally in mexico
this is like a hipster pool party
in nashville hipsters don't get in the
pool so they did dude they got wet dude
somebody invited me into it they got wet
man a lot of urine in that thing too
man was your nephews that's my little
nap caught that little deal right there
they all stayed at the crib oh yeah man
they had fun like fun
they were swimming what else did they do
yeah just eating stuff leaving things
places leaving food places they
shouldn't have
then they came on the podcast too i
heard yeah i want to watch it look funny
cool lifeguard that whole place was like
a vibe this whole little it looks cool
yeah it looks like a cool vibe looks
like it's boogie nights you got andrew
schultz as your lifeguard
it was it was very boogie nights you got
a young bert reynolds as a lifeguard
that's cool yeah it looks like a boogie
night it's like that pool party at
boogie
that's a good call it's exactly what it
was like they had a mustache float
behind the pool like it was definitely
hella hipster out there
but that guy's austin man nice kid right
there i just had a little barbecue at
the crib
tigers outside with his squirt gun
[ __ ] hornate bit him
uh oh you should have heard him squeal
oh [ __ ]
where'd it get him right the arm twice
oh really
it could be that new biden's new hornet
that they're sending out to give put
covet into people
oh yeah yeah they got two of them two of
them oh yeah that's modern
he's black i think it was the johnson
johnson equipment
dude yeah oh joshua yeah johnson johnson
yeah i think so man damn
did he have any friends come over nope
just his brother
chilling boston's fat ass guy in the
pool
oh and here is this that the girl from
uh weak what
is that greta what her name oh you
talking about the yeah
she looks like a mix of that greta the
oh we're going to poison the water
[Laughter]
yeah she's the global warming girl she
looks like a mix of that and the juice
killing off your job calm down lady
she's crying yeah yeah
she does look like her older things
don't work out
that's greta thunder
i mean we are yeah
she's definitely is doing wow that was a
really good call
this lady could play her in a lifetime
movie but she's exhausting if you're a
parent
like if you don't shut the [ __ ] up two
minutes about global warming
i'm gonna freak out like you're sending
me to my room
when the world is burning it's like
it's like yeah yeah [ __ ] you didn't do
your homework you're not missing
[ __ ] global warming right now you gotta
do your homework yeah
you have to speak at the u.n
uh but this woman yeah she kind of
seemed like she was out of her demo but
she made some art and she's got a debate
i can't wait i think she looks diamond
um here from
washington state i have a quick question
for you do you
like water sports here
outside or you prefer just to chill
in there soil and just
lay down on the hammock is she a
is she kidding question my question is
what is your opinion about my fun
fan art that i made it's so crazy it's a
candle
yeah the candle is on apple game game
that's buzz
nice young lady she might be lithuanian
or
polish maybe i think polish power
i like the king in the sting candle when
she was saying water sports are chilling
in the hammock yeah
is she really watching the show just it
just feels like your man forces it
the water is polluted like you pissed in
the bed greta
yeah okay would you stop it with the
global warming
you're gonna be fine
oh these pancakes are cold can you
globally warm them
[Laughter]
like no more jokes greto um
what i like to be hammock or water well
washington state water is
cold water so you can see i like it cold
you can hammock me up
really i like the cold especially in the
summer that's why i don't like i don't
[ __ ] with miami or cancun
the water's too warm it feels like kids
are pissed in the pool
all the time i like that cold water like
the la water's cold
you like that it's hot outside yeah the
cold water that's me and that ice plunge
right there what's in your house
in the garage nothing better for you man
all these little dweebs want to do that
cryotherapy and [ __ ] nothing better than
this for you yeah yeah keep doing that
man don't listen to those people
i did three days in a row how'd you feel
good i felt good the last day i did 10
minutes in there how's that inflammation
on the ass going down a little bit
mm-hmm ashes still popping yeah ass is
still popping it's
still popping i got an ass like a
snowman
you get a hot tub too you gotta got hot
cold hot coals yeah that's a good call
man i have to walk through the house
though and everything would get wet
you can't just walk through the garage
in the backyard or
i'm not doing all that it's a long walk
oh my god my bad
my bad i'm sorry
it's not far but it's not close bro uh
but the crazy thing the guy uh thomas
who from grey block pizza
started making these that's their first
one oh wow that's the prototype well
that's dope
it's pretty cool man they got these gang
gang plates on the side of it are they
all going to have gang gang
plates on the side i don't know they may
do a certain addition
it's like a hot tub but just a cold tub
yep it's a cold tub cold
you keep the water in so then you and
they have like a little machine and a
cage
and um you press the buttons on it and
then it just the water's there all the
time so you go any time
yeah i'm gonna have to hit him up keeps
at whatever temperature man
yeah there you go right there puddle
pumping baby you feel me
gang dawg that christmas crapper baby
that christmas dripper that's a coffin
slowly getting
there okay let's get it down
[Laughter]
that's a lukewarm bath dude the water
that's hosed water
77
okay trust me yeah the first dip was a
little
warm dude the worst thing a second time
and
accidentally peed in there oh my god
it's just the water just chills
no there's a filter that's now that's
one good thing there's a filter
because like bugs from the garage have
been dying in there so
here's another guy who is a pretty
intense uh debate club oh i remember
this guy from homeland
hey guys i got some advice from a cult
leader
it was from the culture i was a part of
obviously
the leader said that in any relationship
if one is unhappy
it's probably because there's something
wrong
with yourself so if you think about it
carefully
when you are alone if you are unhappy
that means you're obviously in bad
company
so learn to enjoy your company first
and then share that enjoyment with
another individual
let me know what you guys think about
that
um gang gang buzz buzz dude that's
mahatma
gandhi right there bro i respect that
guy man that's true man if there's
something wrong
there's something wrong with you if
you're unhappy when you're by yourself
it's
one common denominator man it's you
bubba
and that's the i'll let you take it from
here
thank you i'll let you handle things
with anik so yeah
this is your department this is my
precipice
man i agree dude i know when something's
wrong in my world it's
really inside of me so i appreciate you
reminding me of that man
i was doing okay today um
but yup it's always a journey baby it's
always a joke so he's a fight
before we get to some more debate sorry
about the homeland joke i was just
joking
uh king and her sting it's we actually
someone sent it to cats in the wild
um this is uh basically theo if he ever
gets a [ __ ] together
oh damn oh maybe if you found a lady
it's clean cut jacked couple children
wow
damn nice hair on it i have to get
jacked also can i just have a couple
children
your kid just get kids without getting
shredded it's a lot of responsibility
man that guy's a dime though given that
and then i wouldn't say that dude that's
a man someone sent in pictures of
brendan uh pre-pandemic and post
pandemic after he's been going to zoo
culture here's pre pandemic
and here's postman
that guy is bodied oh definitely the zoo
you've been hanging out around the horse
cages i can tell
baby cause that is that dude climbing
out of the ocean
is that poseidon
man oh dude i bet i missed leg days
though joe
joesthetic i bet that dude's breath
is minty i bet he is oh he's a dime
oh he went to the hospital though he's
flexing dude he probably went there to
drink someone else's happiness got
deleted thank you for your support
everyone
he looks like um what happened to him he
looks like uh dianna knows john a man
from suicide
from uh suicide boys
he looks like a buffalo exotic in that
huh he looks like a
suicide boy that's a good call
a little bit i was having surgery on
all right pretty close not bad same eyes
and hair brain and similarities yeah
same nose structure
but dude that guy's a vein on his arm
i could go through that dude a
vietnamese guy could
lit climb through there dude you could
cook that thing and eat it
that thing is thick howdy fried worms
bro
that dude has some freaking vanish on
them bro
this guy's got bad lighting but he's got
another debate for us
eric out of newark ohio listen to that
old school r b and brought the question
to mine
debate club which group was better
casey and jojo for boys to men
i know you both sang some songs to some
girls back in the day
brandon we're about the same age so can
we go back to the days our love was
strong
[Laughter]
you only know a few lyrics that's all
right dude boys spent all day
casey and jojo only had a few bangers
boys and men
did it right oh yeah dude and then the
guy with the
yeah the guy with the cane would sneak
out of the back base guy
yeah he'd be like i got okay
[Music]
oh that's casey and jojo no
no oh i'll make love to you
yeah these boys and they're all about
consent they're like i'll make love to
you if you want me to
yes
casey and jojo was more like i feel like
kind of
gay bait music yeah
voice to men dude it was a treasure
oh entree love man you're a little more
boys
all that stuff was good man the roast
me's here's me and brendan if we merge
uh people got immersed in a little twink
apparently here's
fandon we'll let him tell it
hey what's going on everybody my name is
andrew um i posted a picture of myself
on the cat's facebook page and asked the
fans to roast me
and here's what they came up with ryan
martinez said
you look like tim robbins and shawshank
after the prison rape scene
all right nick back saying stop man you
gotta what's the lady boys
this guy does look i will say this this
dude would get
banged down okay any rest area
in america this dude would be the
[ __ ]
creme de la creme yeah he would be la
creme lot lizard
oh this dude harvey two percent
milk bro this dude is slinging it
after the prison rape scene all right
nick back said
hot topic version of aquaman all right
hey there's some strong words from a
dude with the name nickelback
[Laughter]
great comeback dan garcia said
you look like you signed up for the army
and bought a four-cylinder camaro
i have an army that is true camaro
that's that army gateway package yeah
right there
dude you got that american flag yeah
they haven't even given you your dog
tags yet but you're all [ __ ] tatted
up
i am in the army but i do not own a
camaro
all right brian carter said oh it's him
so it is
look like a genie if he could only grant
wishes to help you be a date rate loss
that's really creative yeah dude oh good
man
that guy's gonna take someone's job here
hey f you brian that's not funny dude
okay this one jason rolling again said
you look like if two gay men
oh definitely you look like you would be
freaking dancing to some
severe 80s [ __ ] it's raining man in
your crib
hey you man that hurts aaron davidson
said
you definitely moan when you wipe
[Laughter]
kj carr said joe homo exotic
thanks everybody for roasting me i
really appreciate it if everyone said i
was on steroids
i've actually never touched steroids i'm
not even that big just
it's just the lighting you know that was
it so but hey i appreciate everybody for
watching
uh game game buzz buzz
gang gang buddy that guy was great good
video let's send them a nice sweatshirt
or something we'll send them the new
merch
we made the video but oh word uh we'll
send them some merch with some menu
merch
all right we got another speaking of
steroids we got another uh king
understand
what up deal what up brandon
the king of this thing here for you man
i got damn
got skinny as hell man now you can see
it on my face you know my arms are
skinny
my damn chest is skinny i'm skinny man
and i hate it back about four years ago
i was about 200
six foot playing football from the best
i ever felt
it's been hard to get back into the gym
i've tried it a couple times but i get
so close to
getting to where i want to be and then i
just get pissed off myself because i'm
not near what i used to be
so uh kenya is stinging little juicy
juice
now when i was in school i got an injury
a little stinger injury right now i'm
sure you know what i'm talking about
and i lost all the muscle in my arm and
so
my coach recommended a little juicy
juice
and it really brought me back you know
it got me to that 200 that i was
referring to
oh yeah yeah i think i should explore
back into the juicy juice
can you sting let me know guys gang gang
juice juice juice juice juice
man built like [ __ ] jack skeleton man
i think there's some ways to do it man
i think there's some ways to do it man i
i i
enjoyed doing it when i was doing it but
then i didn't enjoy like yeah once you
lose that weight
and you can't pick up the same dumbbells
and you just don't know
yeah you feel embarrassed for yourself
things are heavier even paper is heavier
i remember picking up a paper one time
being like damn this paper is kind of
getting heavy
back on that deck i was losing out of
that deca dude
uh i was also fist fighting black dudes
at parties and [ __ ]
so there's definitely a frozen crowd
yeah there's some pros and cons to it so
he looks like he's gonna find himself
some of those parties machine gun kelly
over here yeah yeah
dude i think uh so i don't know i think
there's some ways to do
it if you like really plan ahead get on
that milk thistle and do like a plan
thing you could go to plant thing and
get on like some trt
i don't know if you need to do like
straight up like deck or win straw maybe
just a little trt
yep and that's much better yeah yeah
that's a much better thing man
is getting on that trt getting on
something that's a little more over the
counter
especially these days there's so many
ways to do it with diet
and safely like don't listen to greg at
golds
about getting on some juice yeah you're
a real guy man
yeah and greg's also gonna be the one
who's gonna sell you the juice dude it's
if you if you need steroids in your town
go to gnc
dude yeah and ask the guy working in
there at first he's gonna say no he
doesn't have him let me say no give me
the real [ __ ]
yeah that's what you do ask him again
okay ask him twice
and that's when he will have it for you
man there's a lot of people
in the facebook group on the clip of uh
you guys were talking about lifting that
were doubting that you ever lifted 315.
feel yeah they're like fat chance
it's not that funny how much is 315
it's three plates on each side 345 345s
i bet i bet theo did it back in the day
i think i
i think people underestimate how
athletic you are dude i i got to
if i didn't get a three if i didn't get
to three plates i got to
two and 35 on each side so that'd be
almost 300
yeah but i bet you could have done 315.
oh so
back in the day when you're sticking
needles on your ass inside the
highway and [ __ ] i could have lifted the
roof off of a building bro i could have
been a [ __ ]
roofer you gotta lift a small prius dude
bro i was lifting some things man uh
i missed it it was fun the hard part is
as you start to get older i found that
if i had a medical condition i would
worry it was caused by that
oh really i didn't like that medical
condition like if you had erectile
dysfunction which i had for probably
about 10 years
oh 10 years oh yeah long dry spout my
man
that's just oh that's the juice that's
just your wiring's not working oh it's
both bro it was bad i had juice
in the wiring and uh
but dude i mean i was still having sex
it was just bad sex
i've always had bad dick sex oh i've
always had bad sex dude you know what
i'm saying it was like a freaking worm
on some uh on some pre-workout
like take that earth worm on a [ __ ]
pre-workout yeah
it was that girth worm on some
pre-workout dude
um yeah it was something that somebody's
probably
eating at chin's house can you bring in
some pictures of when you couldn't
q-tip your ears oh and i couldn't even
get yeah
could you buy something yeah yeah
i'd love to see that i'll have to find
some man i got so i think there's some
photos i think people underestimate how
athletic you were
i was eating yeah i was doing all of it
eating cutlets fighting black dudes
like even when you tried taking me down
in here i was like damn got a little
something something though oh
come in bro i'll put the gas on road
rule days man you're athletic
i'll put the gas on them man there were
some times out there there might be some
little video snippets or something about
to find something good
i got another king of their sting it
from this lady oh
hello damn yellow stoned me up
hey guys my name is kirsten i'm from
utah this is little baby theo
i got a king at her sting it for you
guys dogs
in clothes gang gang buzz buzz
dogs and clothes definitely
nick's here with his dog chewie from
maine obviously
mexico actually oh really mexico yeah
he's born in mexico and he has autism
yeah he's got something i noticed it you
just don't speak english
he was walking backwards in the lobby
for about a minute he hates german
shepherds he might be jewish
oh i can see that hates him he's getting
cuter though i'll give you that
heads up though he did drink half this
espresso
look i think this girl's beautiful man i
think everything's going to be fine
you know i think just look at the way he
kisses on their deck dog
tell him oh that dog a freak theo is a
freak dude
i'll tell you that dude put him on some
dilaudid oh no not dilaudid that'll
[ __ ] kill him actually that killed my
friend
but put him on some uh deca you know
give him some deca
dress them up a little more muscle tees
and [ __ ] yeah
i think dogs and outfits is pretty cool
man i think i think it's cute
yeah i think it's cute man y'all should
get a dog i know
i want one for the for the kids my girl
hates dogs though really [ __ ]
mexicans dude
they don't like dogs no man
wow i never realized that's why that
movie coco is full of [ __ ]
the kid has the dog with him all the
time the new mexican i've ever met they
hate dogs man
have you seen chachi ha hatchy
hatchy that movie japanese dog loves
richard gere
met him at a post office and followed
him for the rest of his life
really yeah hatchy oh that's a real
i i hate dog movies it's pretty bad
yeah it looks [ __ ] horrible it's
pretty bad
looks similar yeah we do what the
daughter is a dime dude
and you do not look like the one on the
left a young richard garrett we look
similar
the one on the right
well you like older women i thought dog
i don't that's young gravy you're
thinking about
oh yeah do you uh theo we got to have
you like do a symbol or something if you
get on camera so
something for the cats fans
oh for in the ufc yeah yeah it's gonna
be so crazy out there
do something like this for us
don't throw up any [ __ ] that you know
you do in nashville all right
we don't need that
[Laughter]
i don't think don't give an okay okay we
don't need that
yeah we don't need that you can't get on
the thing on rogan's seats really they
can
really that's all santino and uh what's
the female comic
opened up for rogan ally max yes here's
a
kovsky ari shafer and uh
they knew they're on tv so they started
making
i will not be doing that
look at that dude next to him looked
over some jealous pervert and the guy
next to him is absolutely losing it
you could do something for us yeah i'll
do something i'll see what i can do
when it's real quiet just yell okay
have you escorted out oh yeah i almost
got it started out last time
you almost called the cops but dude so
many legends out there yeah i texted the
cops on santino dude it got dicey down
there because people were even fighting
it
there was so many fights um i remember
the test fight you went to
porus yeah texting 9-1-1 and being like
there's people beating each other's ass
down here they're like where you said
the ufc
we're not coming uh it's gonna be fun
for you
dude max griffin is fighting stephen
thompson
shawna undercards dope too nico price
michael pereira that's the fight
oh it's gonna be fire that's the fight i
wonder you need to watch him
really yeah he's fun his walk out that's
good yeah he does like backflips and
[ __ ] and
he's waiting for him he's exhausted by
the time he's slow he usually gets beat
up but it's a fun
entrance but last time the guy who he
fought slapped him in the face that
weigh-in so he didn't [ __ ] around and
then
he knocked he knocked him out he's all
the talent he just likes to dance
yeah i'm excited man i'm so excited i i
i just wonder what should i go to the
early fights too you thinking it's go to
all of them yeah don't be that dick that
shows up just for the main event
don't be like those vegans that's spade
does that yeah don't do don't be that
guy
look at him he dances man yeah he does
oh my god you just parkour and then
fights too
wow this is crazy you can't really jump
on the fence like that but
and who's he fighting nico bobby lee
yeah
that looks like it beat the show that's
fat bobby leech
yeah he's fun though look at him wow if
he wins you can get a real dance off
uh yeah you should get there for the
very first fight we'll be able to hear
everything you say
oh that's too early but that's when
rogan goes i'll probably have to go with
him you'll have to go with him if you
don't tickets
unless you may i doubt i don't have my
own tickets
i'm just probably gonna have to meet him
there yeah you'll see the guys that can
give tickets to because by the [ __ ]
main event the prelims like santino's
like this
because you're there for nine hours last
time i was there for nine hours it's a
long night
it was a long night but the first fight
it had brandon davis in it
and that was a bloodbath all the fights
are good like if you're a real fight fan
you want to get there early
i hate the people that just show up for
the main card yeah dude what are you
doing yeah that's like
shaq uh i think spade said he's going
the last couple of ones
no don't be that guy i'm going to be i
think for the whole thing gianni's
trying to go with machine gun kelly is
he really
yeah that'd be dope what a thought dude
he said i'll hold your bullets that's
what he told her
um dude no it's going to be crazy crazy
i'm doing the first uh
fight companion for it too bringing pain
back you're supposed to be on but you're
going to the fights
i know if i wasn't on maybe you can do
the uh if you're in town the wilder fury
companion
that's the next week right is it i think
it's two weeks after
might be the 27th is the 24th yeah first
fight campaign cowbest fight can be
in live think boy channel me cody
garbrandt
josh thompson bradley martin we're only
doing this weekend y'all are doing that
this weekend
wow 7 p.m that's a big group yeah it's
gonna be
sick dude y'all doing live on youtube
live yep damn
channel i was hoping you'd be there but
you'll be at the fights
dang i'm gonna touch and give us a
thumbs up
i wonder if i can tweet at the fights
and try to get it on yeah that would be
i'm sure hey i'm right here
finally right here hashtag thanks dana
do something lame like that thanks dana
don't pay those guys i'm with you man
hashtag ufc 264. i always get it wrong
last thing i got wrong yeah it's tough
to keep up is that indict that's it
all right la first spots uh next week
friday saturday
ha ha shop and friends two shows friday
two shows saturday
get tickets at thickboy.com thick with
three c's
and i'm in tacoma washington end of this
month
uh same thing tickets at thickboy.com
that's it man then the big boy san
antonio september 24th 25th
at the bud light event center out there
the courtyard
out front of 18t arena out there is the
san antonio pre-sale tickets
wow back to san antonio yep you were
just there
year and change again oh was it i
thought you were there a couple weeks
ago yeah i know i wish
i love it um and then also just
announced la jolla comedy store
san diego that is in august end of
august la jolla comedy store
gang baby yeah i'm firing up uh the um
the dark arts tour too we're going to be
taping a special over there in nashville
at the ryman
and that's going to be august 13th and
14th those tickets will go on sale
next week and then i got shows in st
louis cincinnati
charlotte durham chattanooga knoxville
uh portland maine burlington vermont
albany
albany or albany too columbus
cincinnati all those are for sale at
theobland.com
i'm excited i just gotta i'm glad you're
back out there brother i'm excited for
your special too man yeah thanks man i
appreciate it dude gang gang
buzz brendan and theo fighter and weight
i got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso and the
quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not
looking like the type of mind that got a
pack of matches in his pockets at all
times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
trapping couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you